der Luftunterstützung das ganze echt
insigniendruck
[Musik]
zur Meldung an die Frau Bundesminister
das ganze rechts
Frau Bundesminister Oberst Oberfeld der
ausgerückten Truppe meldet die
Militärmusik Oberösterreich eine
Ehrenkompanie gestellt durch die Garde
Insignia Trupp der Luftunterstützung
sowie Abordnungen der Verminderung und
unmittelbaren Einheiten der
Luftunterstützung zur feierlichen
kommandoübergabe angetreten
vielen Dank für die Meldungen mit dem
Festtag beginnen beginnen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es folgen nun die Begrüßung und die
Ansprache des mit der Führung betrauten
scheidenden Kommandanten Oberst georg-
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
ich darf Sie zum heutigen Festakt
anlässlich der Übergabe des Kommandos
der Luftunterstützung hier
an der Flightline des Militärflugplatzes
Hörsching recht herzlich begrüßen an der
Spitze der Ehrengäste in bieten wir
unseren respektvollen Gruß der Frau
Bundesministerin für Landesverteidigung
Magister Claudia Tanner
[Applaus]
in den kameradschaftlichen
Willkommensgruß entbitten wir dem
Vorsitzenden des Zentralausschusses im
Bundesministerium für Landesverteidigung
Herrn Oberst Peter schrottwieser
[Applaus]
respektvollen fliegergruß entbieten wir
unseren Kommandanten der
Luftstreitkräfte und erdschiff
brigittier Magister Gerfried Bromberger
[Applaus]
wir heißen den Militärkommandanten von
Oberösterreich brigittier Magister
Dieter Muhr recht herzlich bei uns
willkommen
[Applaus]
für den nun folgenden Begrüßungen
ersuche ich Sie am Ende dieses Blockes
um ihren geschätzten Applaus
wir begrüßen für die
oberösterreichischen
Einsatzorganisationen den
stellvertretenden Landespolizeidirektor
general major Magister dr Alois lissl
den landesrettungskommandanten des
oberösterreichischen Roten Kreuzes
Reinhard Schmidt in Vertretung des
landesfeuerbekommandanten von
Oberösterreich oberprangrat Ingenieur
Hubert Schamberger
wir begrüßen den Vorsitzenden des
Fachausschusses Luft Amtsdirektor
Regierungsrat Günther dafeit mit den
Vorsitzenden der dienststellenausschüsse
im Führungsbereich der Luftunterstützung
aus der Direktionen in der
Generaldirektion für Landesverteidigung
den Chef des Stabes und
stellvertretender der Direktion 2
Brigitte Magister Wolfgang Priller und
der Abteilungsleiter der Direktion 2
brigidieren Magister Werner Stangl
bridiert die blumeningenieur Peter
Wessely oberstes Generalstabs Magister
Peter Schinnerl derzeit Leiter des
corona-management im Land Salzburg und
Oberst des generalstoffsitzes Michael
Wurm sowie den Leiter der
luftzeugabteilung in der Direktion 5
Brigadier Magister Diplom-Ingenieur Jörg
Freistädter
kameradschaftlichen Willkommensgruß an
die Akademie Schul- und
brigadekommandanten Land und Luft den
Kommandanten der
jahresunteroffiziersakademie oberstes
generalstabsdienstes Magister Klaus
klingenschmidt den Komponenten der
Flieger und fliegerabwehrgruppenschule
brigidieren Magister Ingenieur Reinhard
Kraft den Kommandanten
Luftraumüberwachung mit der Führung
beauftragt Oberst Markus grundreif den
Kommandanten der vierten Panzer
grenadierbrigade präsentieren Magister
Sigwart schier sowie für die Airport
Community unsere neuen Kommandanten der
Luftunterstützung brigidier Magister
Wolfgang Luttenberger den Kommandanten
das 7 Brigade Brigitte Magister Horst
Hofer und den stellvertretenden
Kommandanten des Jagdkommandos Oberst
rudolf-weißenbacher
von Seiten der militärgeistlichkeit
begrüßen wir militär- Johannes
ruppertsberger
in Vertretung des bezirkshauptmannes der
Bezirkshauptmannschaft Linz Land den
Leiter der Abteilung Sicherheit und
Verkehr Magister Dietmar
für unsere zivilenpartner und
Unterstützung und Unterstützer in
Vertretung des Generaldirektors der
Energie AG Oberösterreich
Diplom-Ingenieur Michael Haselauer den
Geschäftsführer des Flughafens Linz
Magister Norbert Raskovic und den Leiter
der ausdruckkontrollflugsicherung Stelle
Linz Herrn Alexander Pils
unsere ehemaligen Kommandanten des
Kommando Luftunterstützung
generalm Magister Wolfgang Wagner
brigidieren Ruhe Andreas Putz und den
vormaligen Kommandant des
fliegeregiments 3 präge dir in Ruhe
Walter Haselsteiner
begrüßen dürfen wir alle Zuseher an den
Bildschirmen
die die heutige kommandoübergabe über
den Livestream auf Youtube verfolgen
Willkommensgruß ich bitte ich auch an
die heute anwesenden Vertreter der Print
und digitalmedien
sowie last but not least ganz besonders
unsere hier angetretenen Soldaten und
Bediensteten des Kommandos
Luftunterstützung als hochwertiger
Ressource und Leistungsträger unserer
Brigade
[Applaus]
hochverehrte Frau Bundesministerin sehr
geehrte Ehrengäste geschätztes Soldaten
und Bedienstete des Kommando
Luftunterstützung
mit 21 juni 2021 wurde ich als
stellvertretender komponenter
Luftunterstützung durch den
überleitungsverantwortlichen der
Direktion 2 mit der
Führungsverantwortung über das Kommando
Luftunterstützung bis zur endgültigen
Nachbesetzung eines neuen Kommandanten
beauftragt
nach knapp zehn Monaten als eingeteilter
Kommandant gebe ich heute mit der Fahne
auch das Kommando über die
Luftunterstützung wieder zurück
unser Verband als eine der beiden
luftbrigaden in den Luftstreitkräften
ist und bleibt ein Einsatzverband und
fähigkeitsträger
das Commander Luftunterstützung mit Sitz
in Hörsching wurde 2008 als
auftragsbezogen gegliederter
verbandsstrukturiert aufgestellt
bereits bei der Aufstellung der begrade
durfte ich ab
2006 als stellvertretender Kommandant
des aufstellungsstabes des Kommando
Luftunterstützung an der Seite des
damaligen Kommandanten des fliegerischen
mit drei und folglich erster
kommandanter Luftunterstützung Oberst
und dann danach Brigadier Andreas Butz
federführend mitwirken
die Zusammenführung der fliegerischen
Einsatzmittel und der zur
Auftragserfüllung erforderlichen
führungsunterstützungs- und
einsatzunterstützungselemente das
umfasst auch die Verbände der
militärluftfahrtechnisch logistischen
Dienste im großen Verband der
Luftunterstützung gewährleisten seitdem
die gerade für pflegerische Einsätze
erforderliche hohe Flexibilität
effiziente Auftragserfüllung und
Schlagkraft
die in meiner commanderführung die Zeit
meiner Kommando Führung war von den
Herausforderungen geprägt die ich
letztes Jahr anlässlich meiner Kommando
Übernahme im Kreis der unterstellten
Kommandanten Leiter und Offiziere des
Stapels definiert habe und nach wie vor
aktuell sind das sind die Sicherstellung
der erforderlichen flugstundenproduktion
auf allen flotten insbesondere bei den
transporthubschrauberflotten als
Voraussetzung zum fähigkeitserhalt in
unseren Kernaufgaben
der Umbau der S70 Flotte im Rahmen des
Evonik exchange program und
Weiterführung des Auslandseinsatzes ab
Herbst 22 auch mit S70 die beginnende
ausfassung des Systems aloet 3 und
Implementierung des leichten
mehrzweckhubschraubersystems AW 169
unter Berücksichtigung aller
Entwicklungslinien insbesondere das auf
das Aufwuchses am Militärpiloten und
luftfahrzeugtechnikern die Infrastruktur
Organisation und Ausbildung
die Übernahme und Ausbildung des
Personals des Systems 105 die
Auswirkungen der Reorganisation der
Zentralstelle von einer stabstruktur in
eine Matrixstruktur die Sicherstellung
der Kontinuität nach 4
kommandantenwechsel seit 2018 sowie die
laufende Führung der Brigade zu
Sicherstellung der an uns gestellten
Aufgaben in ihrem dem Ausland
ich ersuche alle unterstellten die hohe
Einsatzbereitschaft für die die
Luftunterstützung bekannt ist auch unter
den erwerten erwähnten erschwerten
Bedingungen weiter aufrecht zu erhalten
gerade in herausfordernden Zeiten ist es
unsere Pflicht als Einsatzorganisation
die Auftragserfüllung sicherzustellen
und gerade in diesen Zeiten können wir
der Bevölkerung zeigen was wir leisten
können
ohne auf Details einzugehen darf ich
selbst reflektierend feststellen und
melden das Schiff Luftunterstützung in
den zehn Monaten gut auf Kurs gehalten
werden konnte und ich die Brigade nicht
verwaltet sondern geführt habe
unser Verband verfügt wie eingangs
erwähnt über eine hohe Flexibilität
effiziente Auftragsdurchführung und
Schlagkraft das beweisen wir tagtäglich
sowohl im Inn als auch im Ausland
besonders erwähnenswert ist die hohe
Durchhaltefähigkeit unserer Mitarbeiter
und Luftfahrzeuge seit circa eineinhalb
Jahrzehnten im Rahmen der Friedenssaal
den Einsätze am Balkan
kürzlich am 30 März 22 endete nun nach
sage und schreibe 13 Jahren der Einsatz
für die Aloe 3 bei EU vor
mein Respekt und Dank gilt allen
Soldaten und Bediensteten für diese
enorme Dauerleistung
in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung waren
bisher naturgemäß die fliegerischen
Einsätze zur Katastrophenhilfe wie
Waldbrand Schnee Hochwasser Lawine im
Blickpunkt des Interesses der
Bevölkerung mit dem unter meiner
brigadeführung im März durchgeführten
Helikopter tactics curls als Ausbildung
und Einsatzvorbereitung im Rahmen der
militärischen Landesverteidigung als die
Kernaufgabe des österreichischen
Bundesheers konnten wir gerade in Zeiten
der aktuellen kriegerischen
Auseinandersetzung in Europa unsere
Rolle
unsere Rolle positionieren und somit
unseren Einsatzverband öffentlichkeits-
und medienwirksam auch in dieser
militärischen Rolle positionieren und
somit einen Beitrag zu Stärkung des
Vertrauens der Bevölkerung in das
österreichische Bundesheer leisten eine
besondere Herausforderung stellte der
Assistenzeinsatz bei der größten
waldbrandkatastrophe in der Geschichte
Österreichs in Hirschwang an der Rax im
Oktober November letzten Jahres da trotz
mangelder Ressourcen haben wir mit
unseren Einsatzmittel und Kräften
federführend im Rahmen einer
multinationalen evischen Taskforce mit
16 In- und ausländischen Luftfahrzeugen
über 13 Tage einen wesentlichen Beitrag
zu katastrophenbewältigung geleistet
sehr geehrte Frau Bundesministerin ich
möchte mich nochmal für ihren Besuch
während dieses anspruchvollen Einsatz in
hirschwald bedanken die stellt für uns
eingesetzten Partner Bediensteten der
Luftunterstützung ein wichtiges Zeichen
der Wertschätzung da
obwohl unser Verband hochtechnisiert ist
ist es der Mensch und Mitarbeiter der
das System trägt und letztlich den
Erfolgsfaktor in der Aufgabenerfüllung
darstellt
besonderen Respekt sollten wir die hohe
Motivation und Einsatzbereitschaft
unseres Personals als fliegerischer
Einsatzverband sind wir auch häufig
außerhalb der Dienstzeiten und am
Wochenende gefordert um mit unseren
Einsatzmitteln und Fähigkeiten Schutz
und Hilfe zu leisten die hohe
Einsatzbereitschaft wird für einen
Kommandanten unter anderem dadurch Sicht
und spürbar dass
Telefonanrufe zu Alarmierung auch in der
Freizeit ja angenommen werden und die
Mitarbeiter ohne Diskussion ihren Dienst
mit einem bemerkenswerten
Selbstverständnis antreten so erinnere
ich mich an die Weihnachtsfeiertage
rücklandung eines
medic-einsatzes in Wien Schwechat mit
anschließender Notwendigkeit einer
umfänglichen Instandsetzung die wo
andere unter dem Christbaum gefeiert
haben unsere Technik hier drei Tage bei
schlechtesten Rahmenbedingungen Hand
angelegt haben um die
Einsatzbereitschaft des operativen
lufttransportsystems wieder herzustellen
an dieser Stelle möchte ich nicht nur
die fliegenden Gruß ansprechen sondern
auch all jene Mitarbeiter die den
Flugbetrieb und somit die
einsatzdurchführung durch ihre
Unterstützungsleistung am Boden erst
möglich machen
hochverehrte Frau Bundesministerin
geschätzte Ehrengäste
vor ihnen stehen diese hochmotivierten
kompetenten und Einsatzerfahrungen
Kommandanten Soldaten und Bedienstete
der Luftunterstützung als wertvollste
Ressource unseres Verbandes die all das
erst möglich machen
geschätzte Damen und Herren dafür
gebührt ihnen mein Respekt mein Dank und
meine Anerkennung
bedanken möchte ich mich beim
Kommandanten der Luftstreitkräfte für
das in den letzten zehn Monaten in mich
gesetzte Vertrauen ich habe die Brigade
mit Freude mit Stolz und hochmotiviert
geführt
hochverehrte Frau Bundesministerin
geschätzt Ehrengäste
gestatten Sie mir an dieser Stelle auch
den Menschen Dank zu sagen der mir im
Leben und [ __ ] steht und mir seit
Anbeginn meiner Berufslaufbahn vor 40
Jahren und insbesondere den letzten
Monaten meiner Kommandoführung den
Rücken mehr als freigehalten hat liebe
Manuela ich ersuche dich diesen blauen
Blumenstrauß
als äußeres Zeichen meiner Dankbarkeit
für deine Unterstützung und dein
Verständnis für mein dienstliches Wirken
zum Wohle des Kommandos
Luftunterstützung entgegenzunehmen
welches des öfteren in unseren
gemeinsamen Leben ich sage einmal nicht
immer zum Vorteil der Familie war und
nur durch deine liebevolle Geduld und
Fürsorge insbesondere für unsere Kinder
ausgeglichen werden konnte
[Applaus]
dem neuen Kommandanten wünsche ich viel
Freude und Soldaten Glück
in dieser verantwortungsvollen und
herausfordernden Aufgabe als kommandante
Luftunterstützung ich darf meine
Funktion als stellvertretender
Kommandant wieder einnehmen
in der ich in gewohnter Art und Weise
den Verband weiter erhalten bleibe und
zudem den neuen Kommandanten während
seines zeitnah beginnenden Aufenthalt
des in Italien als Leiter des
einführungsteams des leichten
mehrzweckhubschraubersystems ab 169 in
der Führung der begabt in den nächsten
Monaten vertreten
Frau Bundesministerin ich melde mich als
mit der Führung beauftragter Kommandant
ab und gleichzeitig als
stellvertretender Kommandant der
Luftunterstützung zurück Glück ab gut
Land
[Applaus]
ein Koral gespielt von der Militärmusik
Oberösterreich leitet und über zwei
eigentlichen kommandoübergabe danach
wird der Konkurrenz der
Luftunterstützung Brigadier Wolfgang
nuttenberger seine Worte anzurichten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vom Kommando ich übernehme die Pfanne
[Musik]
er bringe dir ich übergebe die Fahne des
Kommandos Luftunterstützung und somit
die Führungsverantwortung über den
Verband
Oberst ich empfinde dich von der
Führungsaufgabe und bedanke mich für
deine umsichtige Führung des großen
Verbandes Luftunterstützung
[Musik]
ich übergebe dir die Fahne der
Luftunterstützung und wünsche dir
ruhige Hand kühlen Kopf und warmes Herz
im Zuge deiner Führung Herr prägter ich
übernehme die Fahne der
Luftunterstützung und damit die
Verantwortung und das Kommando über das
Personal das Material und die
Infrastruktur dieses großen Verbandes
der Luft
[Musik]
hochwertige Frau Bundesminister
Werte Mitarbeiter und Mitarbeiterinnen
des Kommando Luftunterstützung und der
luftunterstützungsbrigade Werte ehren
und Festgäste
auch wenn der Wind hier mir einen
kleinen Streich gespielt hat
darf ich meine Rede dennoch mit guten
Humor und Zuversicht beginnen
als ich am ersten April 2019 vom
damaligen Verteidigungsminister kunasek
mit der Führung der Luftunterstützung
beauftragt wurde wusste ich noch gar
nicht so genau was mich in den
darauffolgenden neun Monaten alles
erwarten würde
ich konnte mir jedoch sehr rasch ein
umfangreiches Bild darüber schaffen
was ein tagtäglich im Inn und Ausland
rund um die Uhr geforderter
hochtechnisierter mobiler und vernetzter
großer Verband zu leisten imstande ist
und welch großartige Leistungen die
Mitarbeiter und Mitarbeiterinnen
über das ganze Bundesgebiet verstreut
erbringen damit das Uhrwerk der
Luftunterstützung rund läuft
diese Erfahrung hat mich besonders dazu
angespart mich um die
kommandantenfunktion erneut zu bewerben
und diesen großartigen verdammt bei den
heranstehenden Herausforderungen zu
führen zu fordern zu motivieren nach
außen kompetent und modern zu
repräsentieren und im Sinne des
verbannspruchs Unterstützung in höheren
Dimensionen im In- und Ausland
erfolgreich zu Wirkung zu bringen
ich darf Ihnen sehr geehrte Frau
Bundesminister versichern dass ich
gemeinsam mit meinem Stab die enorm
fordernde Aufgabe als Kommandant der
Luftunterstützung mit vollem Engagement
und Dienste anpacken und im Sinne der
Aufträge unseres Verbandes und der
luftsteigkräfte auch erfüllen werde
die Verantwortung über eine Brigade die
weit über die Grenzen hinaus bekannt
dafür ist rasch kompetent und effizient
sowohl fliegerische Aufträge im Rahmen
von Einsätzen des österreichischen
Bundesheers im In- und Ausland aber auch
Aufgaben im Rahmen der umfassenden
Sicherheitsvorsorge durch
Unterstützungsleistungen sowie
Katastrophen und assistenzeinsätze
hochprofessionell meinen Vorgänger hat
ja einige Einsätze davon bereits erwähnt
zu erfüllen erfüllt mich persönlich mit
ungemeinem Stolz aber auch ein wenig
Demut
diese in der Vergangenheit schon
unzählige Male unter Beweis gestellte
Leistungsfähigkeit und da oft widrigsten
Verhältnissen wurde auch in der Zeit
meiner Kommandoführung 2019 mehrfach
eingefordert und für die österreichische
Bevölkerung und auch international
eindrucksvolle erbracht ich möchte an
dieser Stelle ihnen dem gesamten Kader
der Luftunterstützung meine besondere
Anerkennung und Hochachtung
vor allem dafür aussprechen dass wir
zusammen bereit sind auch in Zukunft
gemeinsam die hohen Erwartung die hohe
Erwartungshaltung zu erfüllen und ich
von Oberst Georg gesetzki einen
einsatzbereiten modernen und
schlagkräftigen Verband übernehmen darf
ich werde versuchen mein Bestes dafür zu
geben dass ihr in den letzten Jahren
gezeigt ist Engagement nicht umsonst war
und die Luftunterstützung auch zukünftig
dort kompetent Schutz und Hilfe bietet
wo andere dies nicht mehr können
ein Bereich der in den nächsten Jahren
mein größtes Augenmerk erhalten wird ist
der verantwortungsvolle Umgang mit dem
vorhandenen höchst qualifizierten
Personal die Rekrutierung von
ausreichendem und motiviertem Nachwuchs
sowie das glaubhafte vermitteln eines
interessanten fordernden und
verlässlichen Arbeitgebers und den uns
alle anderen beneiden
die Sanierung und zukunftsorientierte
Bereitstellung einer den heutigen
Anforderungen entsprechenden
Infrastruktur und Ziel Frau
Bundesminister haben erst vor zwei Tagen
einen Spatenstich in langen geleistet um
diese in langen Leben zu verbessern
danke dafür
die wohlüberlegte Einführung uns
anvertrauter neuer
und auch der sicheren Betrieb bereits
vorhandenes Systeme ist unumgänglich und
aus meiner Sicht einsatznotwendig
die aktive Zusammenarbeit vor allem mit
dem Jagdkommando der
flieger-gruppenschule sowie den
landbrigaden und den militärkommanden
aber auch den Blaulichtorganisationen
und unserem Partner
sollte auch in Zukunft die
Aufgabenerfüllung unterstützen und die
Einbindung in das militärische aber auch
zivile Umfeld vertiefen
letztlich wird es auch eine besonders
herausfordernde Aufgabe sein jene
Rahmenbedingungen sicherzustellen die
der Verband braucht um sich zukunftsfit
zu machen die Einsatzbereitschaft auf
höchstem Niveau zu halten kohärent und
in kameradschaftlicherweise die
herausforderten Aufgaben anzunehmen und
nach Maßgabe der vorhandenen
Möglichkeiten zu vollsten Zufriedenheit
der Vorgesetzten Ebenen zu erfüllen
denn es liegt an uns den Soldatinnen
Soldaten und sie wie bitte
Zivilbediensteten der Luftunterstützung
gemeinsam mit mir den Kommandanten und
Leitern aller Ebenen den hervorragenden
Ruf dieses Verbandes zu erhalten die
übertragenen Missionen im In- und
Ausland nach besten Wissen und Gewissen
im Rahmen der gesetzlichen Vorgaben zu
erfüllen und dafür Sorge zu tragen dass
sich die österreichische Bevölkerung
auch zukünftig auf uns verlassen kann
anlässlich der heutigen
kommandoübernahme möchte ich der
modernen schlagkräftigen
Luftunterstützung unter meiner Führung
vier Eigenschaften voranstellen denen
wir uns verpflichtet fühlen
einsatzbereit
zukunftsorientiert vorbildhaft und
professionell
einsatzbereit weil uns nicht nur
Umweltgefahren und manchmal extreme
Witterungsbedingungen innerhalb sondern
auch terroristische militante und
militärische Kräfte und Mittel von
Konfliktparteien vor allem auch Gott sei
Dank außerhalb Österreichs bei
Krisenmanagement einsetzen bedrohen
zukunftsorientiert weil wir uns den
Entwicklungen der
Informationsgesellschaft nicht entziehen
wollen und uns regelmäßig modernstes
Gerät zu Aufgabenerfüllung anvertraut
wird mit dem sorgsam umzugehen ist
dementsprechend kommt gediegener aus und
Weiterbildung ein besonders hoher
Stellenwert zu
vorbildhaft weil wir immer mit gutem
Beispiel vorangehen keine Mühen scheuen
und im Rahmen unserer Möglichkeiten
genau dort helfen wo es andere nicht
mehr können
professionell weil wir rasch und
zielgerichtet unsere Aufträge erfüllen
und damit militärischen aber auch
zivilen Bedarfsträgern in Zeiten erster
Bedrängnis kompetent zur Seite stehen
ich kann mit guten Gewissen sagen und
melden Frau Bundesminister dass die
überwiegende Mehrheit der mir nunmehr
anvertrauten Untergebenen diese
Eigenschaft in Eigenschaften nicht nur
theoretisch besitzt sondern tagtäglich
unter Beweis stellt und dabei auch die
Kameradschaft niemals zu kurz kommt
daher freue mich sehr
die herausfordernde Aufgabe des
Kommandanten Luftunterstützung mit
Zuversicht und höchster Motivation
anzunehmen
geschätzte ehren- und Festgäste bevor
ich mich von Ihnen nunmehr verabschieden
möchte ich noch mich noch bei einigen
persönlich und hiermit bedanken bei
meinen Vorgesetzten und vor allem bei
Ihnen Frau Bundesminister für das in
mich gesetzte Vertrauen diesen jederzeit
geforderten und regelmäßig in der
Öffentlichkeit stehenden Verband als
Kommandant zu führen
bei meinem unmittelbaren Vorgänger
Oberst Georg gesetzki für die
Bereitschaft einerseits das Kommando
Luftunterstützung interimistisch mit der
vielen typischen ruhigen und besonnenen
Art zu führen
und mich auch zukünftig wieder mit
seiner Erfahrung zu unterstützen
bei allen Kameraden die mich schon
bisher auf meinem militärischen
Lebensweg begleitet gefördert und
unterstützt haben
und bei den Verantwortlichen
Entscheidungsträgern der gesetzgebenden
Körperschaften der Exekutive der
Hilfsorganisationen der Partner und
Freunde der Luftunterstützung für die
immer wieder bewiesene unbürokratische
Zusammenarbeit auf die ich auch in
Zukunft setze
[Musik]
und nicht zuletzt ganz besonders bei
meiner Gattin Nicole die mir auch in
schwierigen Zeiten Rückhalt Verständnis
und Motivation bietet und immer zu mir
steht
es lebe die Luftunterstützung Glück ab
gut Land
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich ersuche nun den Kommandanten der
luftsportkräfte wegen dir Gerets
hochgeschätzte Frau Bundesminister
hohe Geistlichkeit geschätzte
Personalvertretung sehr geehrte fest und
Ehrengäste sehr geehrte Zuschauerinnen
und Zuschauer wie ihr das Livestreams
hoch geschätzte Militärmusik vor allem
mit diesem beschwinden fliegermarsch
herzlichen Dank Soldatinnen und Soldaten
im Präsenz Miliz Reservestand sowie auch
geschätzte Bedienstete der
Luftunterstützung
wir leben in herausfordernden Zeiten
zwei Jahren Pandemie
und nicht zuletzt der russische
Angriffskrieg in Ukraine der
gleichzeitig regelbasiert
völkerrechtlich die Weltordnung
einseitigen Frage stellt
die Kernaufgabe der Streitkräfte und
somit auch der luftschaltkräfte in einem
demokratischen Staat Rücken so wieder
ins Bewusstsein der Allgemeinheit und in
das mediale Interesse
gerade der Fliegerhorst Vogler in
Hörsching hat hier besondere Bedeutung
nicht nur als zweiter Standort für die
Luftraumüberwachung aber auch aus einer
der Hauptstandorte der Luftunterstützung
alle unsere Einsätze im Inland passieren
aufgrund der Bundesverfassung aufgrund
des wehrgesetzes unsere internationalen
Einsätze beruhen auf Mandaten
internationalen Gemeinschaft die
explizit direkt oder indirekt dem
primären Zweck zu Erhaltung der Menschen
oder Wiederherstellung der
Menschenrechte und der Stabilität in
Krisengebieten abzielen
unsere luftschuldkräfte werden immer
mehr mit komplexen und Hybriden
Herausforderungen konfrontiert das ist
eine Vermischung
von Bedrohungen bis hin zu
unübersichtlichen komplexen und in ihrer
Auswirkung schwer zu erfassen
Situationen führen wie beispielsweise
der drohnenabwehr
um in der Art oft zu Beginn chaotischen
und Aufgabenstellungen
erfolgreich zu handeln bedarf es einer
Klars strukturierten
und vorbereiteter präsenter Kräfte es
gibt kein Rezept für den Erfolg jedoch
das Konzept der zentralen Führung und
dezentralen Führung der luftschildkräfte
ist ein Erfolgsrezept
es bedarf aber auch eine selbstbewussten
großen Verbandes wie beispielsweise der
Luftunterstützung welche aufgrund ihrer
strukturierten
nüchternen staatsarbeit in einem
gegenseitigen Vertrauen in ihrer
Professionalität den Mut aufbringt auch
ins Ungewisse zu handeln darüber hinaus
bedarf es auch eines Verbandes der über
die erforderliche Flexibilität und
handlungsbreite verfügt um Aufträge vom
konventionellen
subkonventionellen bis hin zu hummelnden
also kommandanter luftschutzkräfte kommt
es mir besonders darauf an
die Fähigkeiten zum innovativen in die
Zukunft gerichteten denken so fördern
die Luftunterstützung ist für
initiatives kreatives Handeln bekannt
immer wieder
ereilt uns der Ruf nach strategischem
Lufttransport einerseits für weltweite
Verlegungen
von militärischen
krisenunterstützungsteams nach
Alarmierung oder zu Unterstützung von
diplomatischen Vertretungen Österreichs
oder von EU-Mitgliedsstaaten im
betreffenden Gastland
beziehungsweise zweitens zur weltweiten
Verlegung von nationalen Einsatzkräften
in ein Gastland binnen weniger Tage oder
Zurückführung aus diesem heraus sowie
bei Bedarf Zurückführung von
evakuierungsberechtigten Personen in ein
sicheres Drittland oder zurück in unsere
geliebte Republik Österreich
auch die Fähigkeit zum taktischen
Lufttransport bis hin zu zugstarken
infanteristischen Kräften sowie der
Bedarf von evoquierungen im Einsatzraum
im rastland über 600 Kilometer unter
geringer punktueller bodenluftbedrohung
gehören dazu
die Luftunterstützung stellt aber auch
die Fähigkeit zum Lufttransport bzw auch
zum luftgestützten Patiententransport in
Österreich und im Ausland eingesetzte
militärische Kräfte da
im Ausland erfolgt diese überwiegend mit
dem operativen lufttransportsystem C130
Hercules wo dank unserer Frau
Bundesministerin bereits die
Nachbeschaffung angestoßen wurde
der lufthans das lufttransportsystem
Herkules leistet aber bereits im Chart
oder bei den laufenden Auslandseinsätzen
Mali Libanon und am Balkan wertvolle
Arbeit bei der Versorgung aber
insbesondere bei der Rückholung von
Patienten unserer auslandskontingente
jedoch auch in kovi-zeiten leistete die
Herkules unverzichtbare bemerkenswerte
Dienste im Rahmen von medizinischen
intensivtransporten und zur Evakuierung
bis hin zu einer impfstraße in der
Herkules am Flughafen Salzburg
die Luftaufklärung zu Verdichtung des
lagebildes in Umfeld von schutzobjekten
kritischer Infrastruktur oder zu
schützenden Räumen bei Tag und bei Nacht
aber auch bei schlechtem Wetter diese
gilt es weiterhin aufzubauen um die
Einsatzführung der eigenen Kräfte im
Inland im Ausland aber auch von zivilen
Bedarfsträgern bei
sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsätzen oder bei Katastrophen
ersetzen zur Verfügung zu stellen
die fehlende Fähigkeit der Luftkräfte im
Bereich der einsatzform Luft
nahunterstützung das heißt die
Feuerunterstützung aus der Luft gegen
irreguläre Gegner für unsere Kameraden
der landstuhlkräfte oder des
Jagdkommandos sind bis auf batalog
bataillonsebene abwärts bis auf die
Ebene Zug Ebene Schwergewichts im
Schwergewicht im Bereich urban und
besiedelten Raum weiter zu verfolgen
die Fähigkeiten zum taktischen
Lufttransport von leichten im
französischen Kräften bis zur bataillon
s Stärke in mehreren Kompanie starken
Lift im gesamten bundeskiste Gebiet
sollte durch die Luftunterstützung
möglich sein das ist derzeit wie bereits
auch vor meinen vorinnen angesprochen
nicht möglich
einerseits aufgrund der budgetären
Rahmenbedingungen
diese werden sich hoffentlich sehr bald
ändern sowie auch aufgrund Eltern der
oder alt älter werdenden
hubschrauberflotten somit könnten wir
durchaus noch eine weitere Black Hawk
Staffel aber auch eine weitere 169er
Staffel sehr gut zur Erfüllung unserer
Aufgaben brauchen
wir leben noch immer eine
ressourcenbedingte angespannte
flugstundenproduktion bei der Augusta
bl212 gepaart mit
personellenlogistischen Dienste gerade
die Lehrlingsausbildung in den
fliegerwerften zeigt sichtbare Erfolge
und die Frau Bundesminister wie auch
bereits von meinem Vorreden angesprochen
hat den langen Leben diese Woche vier
lehrgelänge mit
herausragenden Lehrabschluss gratuliert
der Umbau der S70 Black Hawk Flotte in
den Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika im
Rahmen des evonik exchange-programms hat
bereits begonnen und wird noch die
nächsten Jahre andauern
und auch wie bereits erwähnt hat hier
zum Verbesserung der ist also
Infrastruktur diese Woche ein
spatenstichserweitung des Hangar
stattgefunden die ausfassung aloet 3
nach über 50 Jahren im Einsatzbetrieb
der luftschichtkräfte hat aber hat auch
bereits begonnen und wie gesagt dank des
energischen Auftretens unserer
Bundesministerin haben wir noch vor
Weihnachten einen entsprechenden
Vertragsabschluss
zustande gebracht und der Einführung des
neuen leichten mehrzweckhubschraubers
Augusta Westland 169 ist bereits voll im
Gange in diesem Zusammenhang möchte ich
mich auch bei der Direktion 5
insbesondere bei der luftzugabteilung
der dort angesiedelten Projektleitung
sowie auch bei den Abteilungen der
Direktion 2 beim materialstabluft und
bei der Flieger und Flieger
abwehrtruppenschule aber vor allem bei
allen Bediensteten der
luftunterstützungen der Unterstützung
insbesondere im Standorten Hörsching
langenlebern und eigenem Ennstal ganz
bedanken
vor wenigen Minuten habe ich als
sichtbares Zeichen den Wechsel der
Kommandoführung beim Verband
Luftunterstützung im Zuge der fallen
Rücknahme von obersten und der Übergabe
einen neuen Kommandanten brigittier
Wolfgang Luttenberger vollzogen
ich möchte mich ganz herzlich bei Oberst
Georg gesetzki für seine ausgezahnte
Leistung nicht nur über seine der
letzten 14 Jahre ist stellvertretender
Kommandant der Luftunterstützung und
davon die zehn Monate
als Kommandant mit der Führung betraut
bedanken Oberst Gesetzgeber wurde auch
für für den erfolgreiches Wirken im
Bereich der Luftunterstützung durch den
Herrn Bundespräsidenten Alexander van
der Bellen mit dem großen Ehrenzeichen
für Verdienste der Republik Österreich
ausgezeichnet
ob was Gesetzgeber
2017 auch einer der mit Initiatoren der
größten Österreich bislang stattgefunden
grenzüberschreitenden trainationalen
Waldbrandübung im Böhmerwald
wie bereits auch vorher angesprochen im
Oktober November 2021 konnte er genau
diese übungserfahrung bei der bislang
größten
waldbrandkatastrophe der Geschichte
Österreichs in Hirschwang an der Rax in
Niederösterreich erfolgreich
im Einsatz umsetzen ich möchte dir
geschätzter Oberst Gesetzgeber Georg für
eine Leistung
deine Führungsarbeit sowie auch deine
entgegenbrachte Loyalität in deiner Zeit
als Kommando Luftunterstützung danken
und spreche dir meine Anerkennung aus
dem neuen Kommandanten der
Luftunterstützung bringt dir Wolfgang
Luttenberger wünsche ich viel
soldatenglück beim Kurs halten des
Schiffs Luftunterstützung zur Erfüllung
der Kernaufgabe der Luftunterstützung
unter den bekannten Rahmenbedingungen
werden wir noch viele Kraftanstrengungen
im personeller materieller
infrastruktureller und budgetärer Menü
Verbesserungen benötigen die wir nur
gemeinsam mit vereinten Kräften schaffen
werden der oft zitierte Sinnspruch wie
reposionitis mit vereinten Kräften hat
besonders hinsichtlich der Erfüllung der
Aufgaben der Luftunterstützung absolute
Aktualität
lieber Wolfgang
du hast jahrelange Erfahrungen im
Bereich der Militär Luftfahrt und du
bist selbst im einführungsteam der neuen
leichten mehrzweckhubschraubers Augusta
Westland 169 ich wünsche dir eine ruhige
Hand bei den Entscheidungen einen kühlen
Kopf bei der bei den zukünftigen
Herausforderungen Herausforderungen und
ein warmes Herz bei der Menschenführung
für deine neue Aufgabe als kommandanter
Luftunterstützung
dem grünen Stift
der Farbe die Farbe des Kommandanten
bekommst du jetzt dann gleich im
Anschluss
integerty first service sebuff and
excellenspezifischen Gruß glück-abgut
Land es lebe die Luft Unterstützung und
das lebe die österreichischen
luftschaltkräfte danke
[Applaus]
respektvoll bitte ich die Frau
Bundesminister milianischbacher
hohe Geistlichkeit
sehr geehrter Herr Brigitte Bromberger
sehr geehrter Herr Brigitte der
Luttenberger sehr geehrter Herr
Militärkommandant sehr geehrter Herr
Oberst gesetzlich sehr geehrte
Kommandanten sehr geehrte Vertreter der
Einsatzorganisationen Soldatinnen
Soldaten
Zivilbedienstete sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
es ist jedes Mal etwas Besonderes
hierher zu kommen hierher zu kommen nach
Hörsching aber es ist egal wo ich
einsteige immer etwas ganz Besonderes
zum Beispiel in einer Herkules oder in
einen Hubschrauber zu steigen
sich über diesen ganz besonderen Moment
zu freuen wann die Maschine dann abhebt
wenn man die Welt von oben sieht und ich
muss ganz offen sagen das gehört ohne
Zweifel zu einem das schönsten Momente
die man im Leben einer
Verteidigungsministerin haben kann es
gibt andere aber das wissen sehr viele
die heute hier anwesend sind die
Luftunterstützung ist unglaublich
vielfältiger Verband das wurde jetzt
schon in mehreren reden angesprochen und
er kommt
vor allem ständig zum Einsatz ständig
zum Einsatz nicht nur im Inland sondern
auch im Ausland egal zu welchem
Rahmenbedingungen und das waren
unglaublich schwierige wenn wir nur am
die Herausforderungen Denken in
Zusammenhang mit der Pandemie und das
sind so diese normaufgaben die zur
bewältigen sind aber es ist ja
zusätzlich auch immer etwas los der
Umbau der ist 70 Flotte wurde
angesprochen über die ausfassung des
Systems der alway 3 ist schon gesprochen
worden bis hin zu Übergangslösungen im
Transporthubschrauber Bereich aber auch
die so wichtigen und anstrengend nämlich
dass das auch alles zeitgerecht passiert
Anstrengungen Zusammenhang mit der
Vorbereitung auf unseren neuen leichten
Mehrzweckhubschrauber Leonardo AVI 169
der ja gerade im Beschaffung ist ja und
ich sage auch ganz offen es ist
für mich aus der Frage gestanden es hat
mich nicht verwundert dass gerade die
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter des
luftransportersystems C130 im Vorjahr
bei unserem Militär des Jahres in ihrer
Kategorie auch zur Einheit des Jahres
gewählt worden sind
also so einen Verband zu führen dort
kehrt schon einiges dazu das Bedarf ganz
besonderer Planungen das Bedarf vor
allem
Führungsfähigkeit um alle an ihn
gestellten Aufgaben erfüllen zu können
und Herr Oberst sie haben so richtig
gesagt
da reicht es nicht zur zu verwalten
sondern da ist es notwendig zu führen
und das haben sie getan Herr Oberst
Gesetzgeber
einen ganz herzlich bedanken für ihren
Einsatz um das Wohl der Luft
Unterstützung ihre 14-jährige
Erfahrung als stellvertretender
Kommandant der Luftunterstützung die
haben sie wirklich gut nutzen können und
sie haben auch diese Kontinuität im
Verband sicherstellen können das ist
auch etwas ganz Wichtiges sie haben
umsichtig geführt sie haben den
Flugbetrieb Kurt in koordiniert und sie
haben es geschafft dass dort so vieler
personeller und materieller
Entwicklungsschritte die Aufgaben der
Luft Unterstützung mehr als nur erfüllt
werden konnten
sie haben insbesondere auch bei unserem
Projektprogramm unser Herr unglaublich
wertvolle Beiträge geleistet für die
Weiterentwicklung der Fähigkeiten der
Luft Unterstützung und es ist ja
mehrfach angesprochen worden der Oberst
auch von ihnen
beim Waldbrand beim größten Waldbrand in
der Geschichte Österreichs sind
Hirschwang an der Rax haben sie so
vieles einsetzen können dass sie
auszeichnet die übungserfahrung aber
auch dass sie mit Initiator waren der
grenzüberschreitenden Waldbrandübung der
drei Staaten Österreich Tschechien und
Deutschland und hier muss sagen das Lob
dass man über sie gehört hat nicht nur
aus der eigenen Organisation sondern
weiter darüber hinaus das macht mich
stolz das kann uns alle stolz machen da
gehört schon etwas dazu 16 in und
ausländische lösch
luftfahrtzeuge im Luftraum zu
koordinieren sie haben sie angesprochen
das war ein mehr als wesentlicher
Beitrag zur Brandbekämpfung und daher
steht Ihnen diese Auszeichnung auch mehr
als zu das Goldene Ehrenzeichen für
Verdienste um die Republik Österreich ja
was sie sind eines und das habe ich ja
nicht einmal nur selbst erfahren und
gesehen sie sind zielorientiert sie sind
erfolgsorientiert sie sind aber auch
loyal und was man heute so besonders
gespürt hat auch in ihren Worten das ist
die soziale Kompetenz das ist dieser so
wertschätzende Umgang mit der wirklich
wertvollsten und wichtigsten Ressource
nämlich den Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeitern den Menschen ich darf mich
dafür bei Ihnen ganz ganz herzlich
bedanken sie haben den Verband in den
vergangenen zehn Monaten wirklich
großartig geführt und ich darf Ihnen
alles erdenklich Gute auch für die
Zukunft wünschen
ja sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
gleichzeitig gilt es den neuen
Kommandanten willkommen zu heißen und er
ist ja kein unbekannter Herr Präger dir
Magister Wolfgang Luttenberger hat sich
ja seit Beginn seiner militärischen
Laufband der Fliegerei
verschrieben er ist selbsthubschrauber
Pilot absolvierte dann den
generalstabskurs an der
Landesverteidigungsakademie in Wien er
war mehrfach in Auslandseinsätzen tätig
in Kosovo im Bosnien Herzegowina und
zuletzt als stellvertretender Leiter des
fachstabes Luft des
kommandosstreitkräfte tätig Herr
Brigittes wissen sich erworben von
praxisbezogenen Details eigener
Flugerfahrung
überführungsfunktionen auf verschiedenen
Ebenen bis hin zu
projektbearbeitungen und
bewertungskommissionen im Bereich der
Luftstreitkräfte sie bringen alle
Voraussetzungen
die für einen Kommandanten wichtig sind
sie übernehmen das Kommando für die
gesamte Luftunterstützung über alle
Transport und
luftaufklärungsflüge des
österreichischen Bundesheeres und ja es
gibt eine Menge zu tun in Zusammenhang
mit dem Zulauf unserer achten 18 neuen
Mehrzweckhubschrauber bin überzeugt
davon dass sie ihr großes Wissen hier
einbringen werden können und das
Kommando Luftunterstützung mit großer
Umsicht und Engagement führen werden
sehr geehrter Herr Brigitte ich wünsche
euch ihnen für ihre neue Aufgabe alles
erdenklich Gute und viel Erfolg Glück ab
gut Land es lebe das Kommando
Luftunterstützung es lebe das
österreichische Bundesheer es lebe die
Republik Österreich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der Kommandant der ausgeübten Truppe
Oberst Mark Oberfeld meldet gleich der
verbundungsminister den Abschluss des
Festaktes und bitte zum weitere Befehle
danach erfolgt der Ausmarsch der
ehreninformation
anschließend entbieten die fliegenden
Verbände der Luftunterstützung ihren
Kurs in Form eines Überfluges die
Ehrengäste werden nach dem Flug zu einem
Empfang im Hangar geladen
Ehre kommt man nicht
schuld
Ehre fressen
so Meldung an die Frau Bundesminister
und zu mir bitten weiterer Befehle das
ganze rechts
meldet die Beendigung des Festaktes und
bittet um weitere Befehle vielen Dank
für dieses so würdigen Festakt abrücken
lassen
[Musik]